twelve-year-old Nonna is a quiet girl
maybe because of what she's had to
endure her father died when she was four
years old she knows her mother mainly as
a voice on the telephone calling from
Moscow Nonna is growing up with her
grandparents who take good care of her
that's better than the situation of many
other children in the Republic of
Moldova whose parents have left them
behind really good we see simply took
some grandparents are drinkers they
don't take care of the children no one
gets the children up washes them dresses
them prepares meals for them no one
gives them warmth and they miss the
warmth of their parents who are simply
not there known as way to school is
difficult especially in the winter it's
raining hard and the village street is
muddy Moldova is the poorest country in
Europe especially in the villages like
simple teeny here the bitter poverty
drives people to emigrate in search of
jobs
school is the one bright aspect of known
as day he or she has friends and some
fun and she can think about nicer things
her favorite subject is math I like the
instruction the brakes a lot of things
also the other children could be one
fifth of the school children in Capote a
Negro up with only one parent 25
children here grow up entirely without
parents because their parents live
abroad the school has to deal with the
resulting problems lan-evo eldest are
three we exist a politician we don't get
enough support from the state last the
state should require the parents to
clearly give custody of the children to
someone specific the alotta often
someone takes care of the child to a
certain extent but without taking
complete responsibility for him or her
that's Hilton and then it's as if the
children end up on the streets
Saturn school pero para que esta vez
attend room Nonna is shy and usually
sits at the back of the classroom but
she's eager to learn and keeps up with
the material other kids who grow up
without parents often have problems at
school she did see when we come into the
classrooms we often see children who are
completely isolated they sit alone and
draw or they are hyperactive the
opposite extreme we wonder what's going
on in their minds this behavior is often
a result of their parents being outside
the country what that means there may be
a guard up wedding slip about a third of
all Moldovans have left the country most
of them have moved to Russia emigration
is driven by the high unemployment rate
and by the division between Russian
speakers who feel drawn by Russia and
Romanian speakers drawn to the West
Moldova wants closer ties to the
European Union this Russian school in
the capital Chisinau used to have 1000
pupils today that's down to just 400
my solution is in the the problemo it's
a problem at the moment that many
Russian speakers are leaving Moldova
unfortunately the number of pupils at
Russian schools continues to shrink
loosen after school Nona's best friend
Andrea comes to visit together they
watch homemade videos and for a few
moments the quiet girl becomes a
light-hearted teenager until that is
she's asked when was the last time that
her mother was home to celebrate her
birthday
there's no sermon I can't remember the
last time she was home today maybe 2 or
3 years ago did it I don't know there's
a method Nonna talks with her mother on
the phone as often as she can aside from
that while she has his photographs Nonna
dreams of studying law and then moving
to Ireland earning lots of money and
someday building a house in Moldova like
her parents always wanted to some
Moldovans do manage to build a house but
they continue to live and work far away
old people and children remain behind
you